how much of your own experiences get
infused into your show and do you
hesitate before writing these things in
people approach me thinking that I've
been through all of that absolutely
thank you yeah and they're always like
really disappointed that I'm married
[Laughter]
what was really authentic at the
beginning and I wrote it was originally
a play was the humor and the and the and
the tons of phrases that that particular
character would have because that's the
kind of stuff that was cracking me up at
the time and the stuff that I hadn't
really
um seen that much in a character and I
also knew that that's a character I
wanted to play and that he said that
humor the jokes and a lot of the kind of
anecdotal stuff I had Amplified for my
own life or stuff that had funny or
embarrassing happened in my own life and
then weaved a dramatic story out of that
but at the beginning it was like that
happened to me that was embarrassing
that happened to me that was
embarrassing all on Post-it notes and
then cranked them all up so they were
like painfully humiliating and then
found a story within them